stranger things is growing up in season
four with a terrifying new villain and
plenty of nods to a classic slasher
series but that's not the only 80s
classic getting the nod from the show
this year from anime to x-men here are
all the references in stranger things
season four part one warning spoilers
ahead
in the opening scene of the stranger
things season 4 premiere there is an
extended sequence of a paperboy throwing
a bunch of rolled-up newspapers
haphazardly at suburban houses it hits
random parts of the yards including a
chair and the back of the car this could
be a reference to the midway arcade game
the self-explanatory paperboy it came
out in 1985 a year before the fourth
season of stranger things takes place in
fact paperboy came out for home consoles
such as the nintendo entertainment
system or nes a year later in 1986 which
fits with the season even if the scene
itself takes place before the actual
season proper in the game you would play
as the titular paperboy and attempt to
throw your newspaper rolls to the
designated houses the closer to the
house the higher your score though you
would still get points if it didn't land
exactly at their doorstep including if
you broke their windows meanwhile the
player would also have to dodge
obstacles such as cars other people and
in the sequel at least even creatures
grabbing at you from the sewers this
could all be a coincidence real paper
boys do exist or at least used to but
the outfit and bike of the show's paper
boi does seem pretty similar to the
video game character's design
there are a ton of references to
marvel's x-men throughout the fourth
season of stranger things this makes a
lot of sense as millie bobby brown's 11
is often compared to a superhero and her
experimentation is reminiscent of some
x-men arcs such as chris claremont's god
loves man kills furthermore the x-men
comics were increasing in popularity in
the 80s with many of their most popular
arcs like the aforementioned man kills
and the dark phoenix saga released
during that time as for the references
themselves there's the fact that the
dungeons and dragons club led by new
character eddie that mike and dustin
have joined in between seasons is called
the hellfire club a probable reference
to a villainous group of mutants in the
x-men universe other than that dustin
also makes a direct reference to cerebro
a telepath amplifier in the x-men comics
usually employed by professor xavier to
find other mutants it's the name dustin
gives to an improvised computer setup he
made to track down and help his friend
eddie who has gone on the run for a
murder he didn't commit
welcome to cerebro
finally there's the nina project which
is a top secret machine eleven is put
inside so she can regain as well as
amplify her powers reminiscent in look
and function to cerebro
star wars is perhaps the most popular
geek property in the world while it
seems ubiquitous now particularly with
all the disney plus shows it was
similarly inescapable in the first half
of the 80s particularly right after the
release of the original trilogy there is
a lot of ancillary material that existed
during this time between the release of
the original trilogy and the prequel
trilogy this includes kid-targeted
cartoons based on c-3po and r2d2 called
droids as well as tv movies and an
animated series about the ewoks in fact
sharp-eyed viewers can spot will and
jonathan byers watching a snippet of the
aforementioned ewoks cartoon in the
third episode of the fourth season also
two episodes earlier dustin tries to put
on his best han solo impression when
telling his friends never tell me the
odds a quote from the empire strikes
back
one of the most overt references in
season 4 is carrie both the 1974 horror
novel by stephen king an overall major
influence on the show in general as well
as the 1976 brian de palma film starring
[ __ ] spacek this is because at the
beginning of the season will and eleven
are now living in california with eleven
struggling to fit in this is the first
time she's ever been educated in a
public setting rather than being
homeschooled by hopper or in a secret
experimental lab matters get worse
however when she runs a foul of valley
girl queen bee angela angela and her
posse relentlessly bully 11 now going by
her birth name jane which given 11's
latent telekinetic powers makes the
parallels between 11 and carrie all the
more clear when she gets bullied at a
roller rink one of the bullies even
pours a milkshake all over her in a
scene directly calling back to the image
of carrie doused in pig's blood however
the climax of this plotline where she
doesn't go on a telekinetic rampage
seems to be a purposeful inversion by
the duffers
wes cravens a nightmare on elm street
from 1984 is a classic horror film for a
reason it starred robert england as
freddy krueger the iconic knife-fingered
hat and sweater-wearing child killer who
was killed in an act of vigilante
justice and came back as a dream demon
murdering the children of the people who
killed him while ostensibly a slasher
film it is elevated by england's
committed performance craven's dreamlike
direction and the cool gory kills
please god this
god
season four of stranger things revels in
a nightmare on elm street references the
villain uses the fears and anxieties of
teens to kill them even the bloody
deaths of his victims floating in the
air is reminiscent of the first death in
the original nightmare film as well as
the plot about a perceived troublemaker
being framed for the murder however the
main easter egg is the duffer brothers
casting england in the series he plays
victor creel a prisoner who as a younger
man in the 1950s was framed for killing
his children he puts in a great
performance even if it's a more
sympathetic one rather than the
villainous work you might expect
the popular tabletop role-playing game
dungeons and dragons or dmd has always
been a big part of stranger things in
fact the pilot episode opens with the
main quartet mike dustin lucas and will
playing the rpg it even plays a pivotal
role in the characters defeating the
villains of the upside down throughout
the series this includes helping them
understand the fourth season's new
villain which they've dubbed vecna based
on a wizard who harnesses the powers of
a dark realm however being said in the
80s it means that the show is finally
tackling the satanic panic of the era
during this time certain activities like
playing dungeons and dragons were
considered legitimately evil in a
supernatural sense this was spurred on
by a growing evangelical movement during
the conservative reagan administration
the artist jack chick of the infamous
chick tracks comics was an acolyte of
both extreme evangelicalism and
conservatism and immediately jumped on
the anti-d and d bandwagon he wrote and
drew the strip dark dungeons where a
girl uses spells she learned from d to
control people in episode 2 of season 4
basketball star jason whose girlfriend
eddie was framed for killing retells
nearly the same hypothetical about why
eddie a known d d player is dangerous
eddie munson
he's a part of that freak devil called
hellfire
at the end of season three of stranger
things viewers saw hopper get blown up
during the last episode sacrificing
himself in an attempt to stop the
encroaching upside down however we also
got a tantalizing after credit scene
that hinted that he might be alive in a
russian prison this means that season 4
deals with joyce and murray attempting
to find and rescue hopper from the
soviet union this is set in motion when
they find what looks like a ransom note
and a phone number to call when they
dial the number they get in touch with
the russian who claims he can get hopper
to safety for a price however when joyce
initially calls the number the dialed
numbers play out the notes to the
original mission impossible theme for
those unaware the mission impossible
series starring tom cruise is an
adaptation of the cold war era tv series
from the 60s starring peter graves there
was even an ill-fated reboot in the 80s
the decade stranger things has set this
also alludes to the ensuing plot as
joyce and murray have to deal with spies
double crosses and even the use of
disguises in classic mission impossible
fashion it's also worth noting that one
of the tom cruise starring films started
with ethan hunt escaping a russian
prison so it's clearly not a coincidence
aside from star wars the lord of the
rings might be the biggest nerd property
on the planet written by english
professor and linguist j.r.r tolkien the
lord of the rings is about a group of
dwarves elves hobbits humans and wizards
sent on a quest to destroy a magical
ring so an evil warlord named sauron
can't use it to control the world the
backbone of all modern fantasy stories
even stranger things owes a lot to
tolkien so during the penultimate
episode of season 4 it's no surprise
when eddie compares the mission to stop
vecna with stepping into mordor to stop
sauron while they spout off quotes and
character names it comes into clear
focus later how similar the upside down
actually looks to mordor eddie also
mentions the burning of the shire better
known as the scouring of the shire
outside of a small flash forward this
isn't in the movies it happens after
sauron is defeated it's a reference to
the wholesome town of hawkins succumbing
to hate and fear as well as the
supernatural threat of the upside down
the grandfather clock motif throughout
the fourth season of stranger things
seems out of place at first glance
eventually it is made clear that such
references are to the original creel
house where one first realized his
latent and devastating psychic powers
however more than that this is a
reference to the classic graphic novel
watchmen by alan moore and dave gibbons
clocks play a big part in the comic in a
couple ways for one there's the doomsday
clock ticking ever closer to midnight
there's also the watchmen character john
ostermann who is put into a particle
accelerator and ripped apart into atoms
but eventually reconstructs himself into
an all-powerful superhero in the comics
jon osterman's father was a watchmaker
and it is heavily implied that his
father's tutelage gave jonathan the
knowledge of how things are put together
and is what helped him reconstruct
himself after being split apart this
becomes more clear as one describes his
backstory to 11 and nancy in a montage
scored by philip glass's pruitt igo and
prophecies the same song zack snyder
used in his 2009 watchman feature film
adaptation
though the seminal dystopian sci-fi
anime feature akira didn't come out
until 1988 two years after the fourth
season of stranger things is set the
manga that the anime was adapted from
initially came out in 1982 much like the
tale of 11 the akira story focuses on a
group of children with latent psychic
abilities being controlled monitored and
experimented on by a corrupt government
agent that is until one of the children
tetsuo escapes and wreaks havoc on new
tokyo tetsuo eventually is overcome by
his own abilities becoming horribly
disfigured this is very similar to the
fate of one who tricked eleven into
freeing him this includes the
disfigurement with the tentacles being
similar to the veiny tentacled hand of
tetsuo during the climax of akira
this place
and the people here
[Music]
are not what you think
as well one has a very anime look with
his hair though blonde styled in a way
similar to tetsuo as well as his face
being lit in a way that makes his facial
features reminiscent of the character
even the final disintegration in the
show initiated by 11 has visual
similarities to shots from the classic
anime and manga check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you